robotic cars are coming but will they be
able to make three-point turns we'll
find out you on musk announced during a
conference call that a hands-free
electric car is hitting the market in
just six months the coolest part of musk
skål may have been when he announced
that if you're on private property
drivers will actually be able to
remotely some in their vehicle and when
they arrived home after Drive Tesla
owners will also be able to send their
car back to the garage without actually
having to manually Park them alright so
you guys know I love this kind of story
right I love all this futuristic stuff I
love all the robotic stuff I love
wondering when they're gonna come and
destroy us what well we didn't show in
the package there is that a lot musk
also said that eventually humans driving
could become illegal because it would
then be more dangerous because you'd
have humans driving with these robots
then he walked that back a little bit
because obviously he has taken Tesla so
people started freaking out about that
I've been in one Tesla once it was after
a party at your house and it wasn't your
Tesla though yeah do it okay but not
that it was cool futuristic operation I
was in a Tesla want it at the pop-up
store at Century City Mall yeah it is
the greatest car I've ever just see yeah
like I didn't go anywhere I didn't take
a little test drive
I just sat in the car yeah and they were
like can you come out of the car now I
drove it it's pretty for I mean
everything's digital is cool but that
ended in and of itself it's not a
robotic car but these things are coming
yes so should I start with the fear
question or was just the cool quite okay
take it either all I have to tell you
sister day no lie I was in Beverly Hills
driving one of those one-way streets and
a woman came at me in her Jaguar and I
thought you know if her car was a robot
it would have known better she clearly
does so you're pro a robot a pro robot
car at this point
robot car well I would say next to Ted
Cruz running for president this is the
dumbest idea in the history of dumb
ideas okay every but what does health
traffic it's gonna be like Minority
Report and we'll be able to line up all
the car
now where do we all live California
three busiest freeways in the modern
free world the 405 the 101 in the 10
even the next list followed by some [ __ ]
ass freeway in Venezuela would you like
you can play chess in the traffic jams
the clock just right and is and is real
I think is another bad one yeah
sometimes I'm on the 405 quick story
dead stop
I'm in the center lane cars everywhere I
look front cars right side behind and I
go no one's moving we're all just
sitting there and I go oh my god I'm in
the matrix like I checked I checked my
shrink tour to see if there's one of
those butted blood sucking the life out
of me driving in this town whether
you're in a robot car or a car driven by
uber lyft or sidecar it's still a
nightmare it doesn't matter this plane
crash was what they call wire with it
with a plan they move everything
digitally so there's no wire connecting
to the aileron and the the flaps so now
we've got a robot car and if there's a
software glitch or it's unhackable yeah
like like the IRS and everything is
unhackable right a horrible idea we're
gonna change our lives at all so you're
going directly to the to the negative
side of stuff which is on the future
stuff where I always end up hearing one
way or another but there could be some
short-term positivity here that if
robots were driving cars and you took
that human error outright it might help
traffic it might be good for a while
before the robots turn on us you know
I'm tired of waking up and not having
any hope when I was a little kid I saw
the movie sleeper yeah and you know
Diane Keaton Woody Allen down that
little cool car and it drove them
somewhere I wanted one of those damnit I
want my weight down this hill until it
broke down and they found a VW Bug 67
crank top in the cave that started right
up okay regular gas wait how did they
have sex in sweeper I can't really they
did some gear on yeah that's really but
really those window when you invent
those get an orgasm a truck that's what
I'm saying that's where this all ends up
right like this all ends with it we're
just in a pacification of us and we're
just gonna end up in a pod and we're
part of this
now my husband this morning was saying
that he also as Elon wants to make this
tube sister yeah from huge hyper hyper
hyper loop right right and and my
husband Bob was saying that he just
doesn't want to feel like a hamster and
a Habitrail I live for that robotic car
is great idea gonna clean up traffic or
are they coming to kill us let us know
your thoughts in the comments right now